how they'll look back at this period of
history at that and be like wow what did
America become that the first son was
like just given a little pat on the
wrist for having something that would
have thrown other people yeah yeah I
left this response to that was that it's
actually it's because of white privilege
nothing to do with Joe Biden and
Corruption because of that it's
specifically because Hunter is white
because all white people would have been
treated the same in that situation and
Ian it very very it may very well be
that in a hundred years the way they
look back on this moment is it was the
beginning of the Fall
they perhaps will write in the future
and say kids ah there's always something
the first fall of the American Empire
started in what date and they're going
to be like July 4th 2023 and what caused
it finding Hunter Biden's cocaine that's
right kids it is pretty nasty it's like
what kind of Faith Can you have